this much debt to GDP is leading to
inflation for the average American that
means they've given up a month of salary
that's a huge impact they were still
conducting quantitative easing and had
interest rates at zero and we had seven
percent inflation in the United States
of America talk about being behind the
curve one of the great things about
America is the the way in which people
rise and fall people at the top racket
in a couple Generations they'll be at
the lower brackets and vice versa people
at the bottom of the ladder can climb to
the top and it's still the case that you
can do that do we have free markets in
the United States I think we still do
they're not as free as they used to be
and they're not as free as they should
be people will look at what's happened
in California and say okay which future
is better for us California is failing
Florida's succeeding all right guys bang
bang I've got David here with me uh I
thought a great place to start a
conversation is debt to GDP in the
United States at 140 percent uh that is
not a good situation to be in
and most people as part of this
conversation talk about stop spending
stop spending stop spending which I know
that you and your organization are very
worried about uh but also it is called
The Club for Growth for a reason uh can
we grow our way out of this GDP uh ratio
is it possible for the United States to
Buck the trend and get back to a high
growth environment it absolutely is
possible pump
um you look at the productivity of the
United States and the ability to bring
new technology new innovation into our
economy
um we're we're by and far the world
leader on that now does that mean that
we should keep this profligate spending
and adding more and more debt no we've
got to stop that because we're seeing
now we've reached the point last year
where this much debt to GDP is leading
to inflation we're now at eight percent
uh one of our candidates figured out
that basically for the average American
that means they've given up a month of
salary the buying power of about a month
of their their earnings that's a huge
impact yeah families in this country so
we can't just keep spending we have to
have discipline on that Washington's
totally lost that discipline during
covid and they think they can keep
spending but we can grow out of it when
we unleash that Innovation so that there
are two sides of the equation hold down
the spending and then hold down the
regulations the taxes all of the parts
of government that are break put a break
on the growth of the economy unleash
that growth we've seen it before Reagan
did it in the 80s we we grew
phenomenally Clinton did it in the late
90s when we unleashed the power of the
tech industry we can do that again now
so when we think about uh these past
environments where we've seen impressive
growth in the United States
there's a couple of different points in
American history that I think we can
look at and if you look from the the
1870 to 1970 time frame incredible
growth and credible Innovation all that
obviously the late 90s is another one as
you mentioned
um is it just a remove regulation and
kind of let the free market ride and
that usually leads to growth or are
there other ingredients that are needed
in order to really kind of stoke that
growth one of the key ingredients is
this sort of you can call it animal
spirits or this desire to innovate to
search out new technologies to to dream
big
um you know the person who symbolizes
that most right now is probably Elon
Musk right who would have thought that
that you could create a company based on
an electric vehicle 10 years ago he
dreamed it up and is doing it and all of
those Innovations have Ripple effects
throughout the economy with the new
approach new technique and you look back
in history Henry Ford did that in making
cars where they used to be handcrafted
individual Vehicles he said now let's
Mass produce it set up the assembly line
you saw moving forward in the after
World War II the unleashing the power of
all of the new technology that was
developed then the moon landing gave us
a whole nother set of Technology
computers that started in the 60s and
and became popularly available in the
late 70s and 80s I lived through that
era where we didn't have any computers
in college the way everybody does now
um and then the tech Revolution also in
in life sciences biotechnology was a
whole new way of looking at disease and
creating
Therapeutics that would be able to cure
diseases that were previously
untreatable
America has this ability to imagine the
unimaginable
um I'm a big science fiction fan I think
that's where a lot of these ideas come
from people dream about a future that is
fantasy right now and then they think
well how do we get there and the rest of
the world copies us we lead with that
imagination and that Innovation and part
of what Club for Growth says is let's
let that flourish let's make sure we've
got a country where people are free to
follow their dreams I've seen a couple
of folks on Twitter and in private
conversations over the last two years or
so say something to the effect of uh man
it hit me everything we use on a daily
basis was because somebody either had
the courage the conviction or put the
energy time and money behind building it
and there was one individual in
particular who's in the tech industry uh
his founder and he was tweeting and he
basically was like
that building wasn't there at some point
Like Somebody went and built that
building right and if you think of like
this road was not here until somebody
said we should put a road here they set
the plan they went and got the approvals
and they and they laid the the asphalt
and kind of did the work and so in some
way it's an elementary view of the world
of like walking around with kind of a
childlike Wonder it's like wow you know
somebody built all of this but at the
same time it's a reminder that like we
will not grow we will not change we will
not improve unless somebody says I will
be the one to go do that and Elon
obviously is doing it in very kind of uh
uh public uh manner with things I think
people think are cool and interesting
but it also can happen on your local
community or in a other type of
technology that maybe isn't you know
let's go to Mars uh but it does take
individual citizens to actually do the
work to move us forward well little
things make a huge difference going back
in history again somebody looked at a
four-story building which five story
maybe that was as far as people were
willing to climb up on their stairs and
said well what if we make like a train
that would go up and down instead of
horizontally and and they invented the
elevator right and that let us build
these skyscrapers
um it's those little ideas that people
have
really from interestingly enough from
the founding of our country built into
our constitution is the notion that
we'll reward people for that that's why
we give people patents and protect
proper intellectual property rights and
it's right there at the founding of
America where our founding fathers said
we need to incentivize that because
that's going to build the future yeah I
have this uh book it's kind of an
oversized hardback book
um and in it it's a a very visual thing
every page has some sort of imagery
design diagram uh patent or something
from history it's all about science and
technology and uh one day I was flipping
through it and one of the pages I just
happened to come upon was uh a man's
forearm and it had the arteries and
veins and it was a lifelike image but it
was showing that somebody one day just
put their finger onto it and said oh
wait something happens when I touch that
and they were trying to figure out like
what is this thing in my arm and you
remember that like there was a point
where we didn't understand our own
bodies merely to the degree we do today
same thing when it comes to elevators
building Urban density and kind of all
these different ideas but it also
reminds us like there's things that will
be invented in the future or will be
discovered in the future that we have no
clue about today right right and and
there's things about our own bodies
there's things about uh technology but
there's also things that will get
created and I think that's really where
you seem to be the most uh kind of
excited about and say hey look we need
to allow for that to happen in the
United States or we risk it happening
somewhere else and us not reaping the
benefits of it that's right
um and and we're in a competitive world
right now we I think we have a natural
advantage that we take that imagination
and incentivize people to go do
something with a tinker with that in
their garage and create something new
the rest of the world tends to copy us
right and they're very good at that the
China Korea very good at okay America
has this technology how do we refine
that copy it make it Mass producible
um and and we're an organization that
believes in the world free trade
um we've come to realize that there are
adversaries out there like in China who
will weaponize that and try to hurt the
United States so we we can't allow that
to happen but when countries sign up to
freedom and being work partners with
each other there's a great flourishing
of wealth that comes back and benefits
us here in the U.S but benefits
everybody in the world yeah one of the
key ideas I think of the work that you
do today is this idea of prosperity and
opportunity comes from economic freedom
and uh given the world that we live in
especially in the western world uh over
the last two or three years economic
freedom continues to be brought up uh
but we come from some level of financial
privilege right if I go to the ATM I get
my money out of that economic freedom
means something different to us than it
does to somebody who is literally
financially oppressed or worried about
the confiscation of their wealth or the
devaluation of their currency literally
to zero on another parts of the world
but when you think of that term economic
freedom here what does that mean like
how do we wrap our heads around what
exactly encompasses economic freedom I I
think that's a great question pump I
think of it fundamentally as each person
can seek to pursue their dreams
um that that they can look for a job
that fulfills them they can decide I
don't want to work for a big Corporation
I want to try creating my own small
business whether it's a dream to set up
a taco stand somewhere or a dream to say
I want to be the new innovator in
financial services let me see if I can
pull together a group of people to I'll
find some really smart people who know
Tech computers and find some marketing
people pull that together and see if
it'll work and our economic system
rewards that it it incentivizes people
who have money to invest the capital in
that but for that to happen we have to
make sure they get the return on their
investment right so you look at Venture
Capital folks they're they're picking
you know maybe a dozen opportunities
they see might work and 10 of them might
work a little bit and two of them take
off and that's how they get rewarded for
that if we have a tax system for example
that says no when when they take off and
you make a lot of money we're going to
take 90 percent of that for the
government well that destroys the whole
incentive for people to use their money
to help somebody else pursue their dream
so we we at the Club for Growth look for
ways in which we can lift those barriers
that government has put one either
unintended barriers that happens a lot
they they you're trying to do something
good protect people but they
inadvertently take away that freedom and
that initiative and the reward risk
calculation or sometimes we see people
push the government they they use the
political process they come in and Lobby
and they say hey why don't you adopt
this new rule we can follow the rule but
what they know is their competitors will
have to spend a lot of money to do that
so it gives them a competitive advantage
and one of the reasons we try to keep
the economic activity outside of
government is that when you bring it
into government
automatically it becomes politicized and
and their winners and losers based on
who can do the best in politics rather
than who does the best in serving their
customers or building a new plant or
just discovering a new idea yeah when we
think of taxes I think that's the one
that uh the average person interacts
with the most right if you don't run a
business if you don't have a a business
that operates in a highly uh kind of
regulatory environment the regulation
that you deal with the most is taxes and
uh sales tax and things like that I
don't think people whether they should
or not are very concerned about is it
you know six or seven percent that kind
of okay the one that they see the one
that they feel and the one that I hear
people talk about the most is income tax
um
there seems to be a psychological
barrier and I've talked about this uh
quite a bit recently but 50 percent
if it's under 50 is my total tax rate I
am the majority stakeholder in my life
right once it goes over 50 percent the
individual is now the minority
stakeholder in their economic production
right which seems kind of weird and so
how do you all think about income tax
and and this 50 kind of on either side
and kind of where we're headed when it
comes to uh these types of almost
personal regulations yeah and by the way
I'd want us to drive that down to about
20 to 25 for the government and the rest
let people keep what they make
um there's a real effect people people
figure I'm doing all this work or I'm
taking this risk with everything I own
and the the government's taking half of
it or more of it ah let me I can just
invest it in something that's tax-free
like a municipal Bond I don't have to
worry about it I don't have to take the
risk and and I'll be okay so you get
that it's it's a real site ecological
phenomenon where people it becomes a
barrier for them working it becomes a
barrier for them taking risk and and
putting their heart and soul into it
there's a there's several things that
are problems in the tax code that's one
that's the biggest one as we increase
that income tax rate we see less and
less economic activity less and less
people willing to work willing to invest
willing to take risks and that makes
sense right I think this is like a
really really important point is if
people have less resources and they also
have a lower and lower incentive
from a reward standpoint yeah they do
less work they're less productive they
make less investment like like there's
this cascading effect of uh every
additional point of personal income tax
that is levied against an individual it
drops the incentive and it also means
that they have less money in their
pocket to do whatever activities they
want to do whether it's economic
consumption or it is economic investment
yeah I mean think about it this way
somebody's looking if I'm going to bust
my tail and and put in 24 7 to do this
and then somebody else gets all the
benefit of it I mean at some point you
just get discouraged and say why don't I
do something easy and relax and enjoy
um the there are also some other things
that happen one the compliance costs we
we get an increasingly complex tax code
right you you have to once you get
really engaged in something you got to
hire an accountant to tell you what you
can and can't do and half the time they
if they're honest they tell you I'm not
sure about this but let's try to do the
best we can that's a ridiculous way to
set up a tax code and we're all for just
a flat tax make it very easy and simple
this is what you owe low fill out the
forms send it in and don't worry about
all these different deductions and steps
you got to do
the other thing that happens when you
make it complicated like that is it
distorts what people put their money
into I mean we see a lot of people
investing in windmills 10 years ago
because the government created this
super tax incentive where people made
huge profits selling the materials for
windmills now would they have done that
without the tax incentive maybe maybe
they would have done something else that
would you know build photos that take
cells and put that on their roof instead
so it distorts the choices people make
the complexity is hilarious I think
right and it's like sad that it's
hilarious but uh there's the classic
Donald Rumsfeld every time he filed his
tax returns he sent a letter in and he
was like I'm college educated my wife's
college educated we've done the best to
our ability to actually figure out what
we owe but there's no ability for us to
say with confidence that this tax return
is correct and hopefully my lifetime
will simplify the tax code right and you
read it and you're just like that's a
pretty baller letter
who wrote some of those tax bills yes I
think that's one and then the second
thing is
it cracks me up that it is so complex
that there are memes that go viral on
the internet all the time that are like
you're telling me the government knows
what I owe but they just want me to like
guess and try to send them how much I
owe and then they tell me later whether
I got it right or not right that's right
like it's kind of crazy that's right
well this has happened to me you get a
little Bill saying you got this one
wrong you know and it's always send us
more they never say well we'll reduce it
right they one time one time I I uh I
think I got like a 80 Checker you know
sounds great I almost framed it I know
this is really funny I was like oh my
God it's amazing it came on like a check
with the green paper and I think the
Statue of Liberty was on the back side
everyone in a million the and and your
accountant always says well it's easier
to just pay it don't don't kind of argue
about it David it's crazy and when you
think about taxes obviously income tax
is the big one
um it does serve as an incentive and as
a stick right there's kind of the carrot
and the stick that happens and for
people who listen to this show one of
the things a number of people did is
they all moved to Puerto Rico yeah and I
remember thinking to myself at first
when I heard people say oh yeah that's
why why are you going there and then oh
there's a tax incentive right and then
you learn more and more about the tax
incentive and you're like
you got to be there for five years right
like like it's not like uh oh I'm there
kind of sort of there it's like you
gotta be there because it's such a big
incentive and so what it showed me was
like people are literally willing to
uproot their life yeah take their
families and move
completely you know across the Gulf of
Mexico right right to an Island an
island because of the incentive that's a
pretty damn good incentive but it also
then tells us like wait a minute are
they running from the stick or are they
running to the carrot yeah right like
how much of it is the incentive versus
no the the punishment the the penalty
has gotten so egregious that they're
looking for anything that is a better
situation okay guys you might think that
okay X
sounds like a new genius football
formation it's actually not Charlie it's
your new favorite crypto trading app
you heard the man
no that's right well you see that in
folks moving from California
um and and I know a lot of folks who've
moved to Tennessee a lot of come here to
Florida and they love California it's a
beautiful state they love living there
they raised their family there and it
just became too much and and so it was
the stick became too burdensome and they
finally said uh we gotta move put put
down roots in a new place I think the
top tax rate in California if I if I
remember correctly is 53 and there was
uh I'll call it a rumor because I don't
know where it was in the legislative
process but there was a proposal that
was making its way through uh that they
potentially would increase it by another
five percent so the top tax rate would
end up being 58 and it goes back to the
psychology right 49
chilling 51 a lot of people are like hey
I I don't feel good about this
if we saw 58 yeah I think there's a lot
of people who would be like I'm out of
here yeah right like like how do you
sort of do that because at 58 well what
stops you from 60 right what starts you
from 62. like at some point did we just
get you know is it 75 yeah and then then
you're working for the working for the
man yeah yeah it's um it's custody what
about like death tax and other types of
taxes that I think uh as people build
more wealth it becomes more of an issue
that they worry about but but still uh
it is a large tax uh uh that usually is
around 50 on very large uh pools of
wealth how do you all think about stuff
like that
um one we think it should be eliminated
it's a an extra tax a double or triple
tax on what people have earned and the
money that they've made and the we see
incentive effects there I mean Florida
was one of the first states to to get
rid of the estate attack and way before
the differential on state income taxes
that attracted a lot of wealthy people
when they retired nice place to retire
the infrastructure is there for us
doctors are there and we avoid this
estate tax people one they don't want to
be taxed twice but second that's a very
much a human emotion human nature to
want to leave something for their kids
right and so they they spend a lot of
time effort figuring out how do I
maximize that when when I leave you
can't take it with you but there's a big
desire to leave it for to the people
they love what is the logic behind the
death tax like like if we were to talk
to someone who says no we should
absolutely have that it should be 50 or
whatever like is it just a revenue
source for the government or is there
some other uh logic yeah I well there's
also this this sense of fairness that
when somebody's made wealth they ought
to give a big chunk of it back that
society's entitled to it uh I guess if
it's hard for me to make this argument
because I don't really believe it but
but I could hear somebody saying
um well it wasn't just you and I guess
the famous Obama you know you didn't
build this the government did Society
let you build your wealth now you owe it
back when you're when your life's over
well
my answer to that is why do you owe it
to society or why why don't you pick who
in society you want to give it to some
people give it to Charities some people
give it to their children
um the other thing pumps that that we
think about wealth being unfair because
it creates for this individual or this
family a huge advantage one of the great
things about America is the the way in
which people rise and fall the we don't
have static Elite Rich classes the way
European
Aristocrats used to be we you look and
that's to me one of the most important
indicators of whether our society is
working well or not people at the top
racket in a couple Generations they'll
be at the lower brackets and vice versa
people at the bottom of the ladder can
climb to the top in America and it's
still the case that you can do that one
of the great things we'll we'll talk
more about Bitcoin and crypto is we're
seeing that happen you know people who
were at the bottom of the Ledger and
said this is interesting I'm going to
invest in it and suddenly they find
themselves with real wealths and they're
investing it and creating a life for
themselves
um it it's the American dream
and one of the unique things about our
society we were talking earlier why are
we good at growth it's one of the
reasons we are is that you've got that
Dynamic where people are not ossified
into stratists that based on where
you're born it's based on your skills
yeah one of the uh the jokes in a lot of
the kind of a family office world and
and uh the asset management world is
like uh you don't need the death decks
because you just need to wait three
generations and they'll for sure give
the money back exactly do something dumb
that somehow will disperse it back into
society either through consumption or
stupidity yeah totally and and I think
it goes back to this idea of like free
markets right to some degree uh
we as a society place an emphasis uh
maybe lesser emphasis than historically
but we still place an emphasis on free
markets the question is just do we have
free markets right I remember during uh
2020 with the volatility and stock
market stock market would open it was
Limit Up limit down almost every day and
they were they were hitting these uh
kind of circuit breakers and we were
literally shutting off the stock market
and then putting them back online and
you look at this and and there's reason
right there's obvious reasons as to why
we do it
um but we live in a country where the
stock market has closed more hours than
it's open in a week yeah and you start
to think about the stuff you're like
okay maybe we don't have a hundred
percent completely you know uh
ungoverned free markets
and hours of operations are great
because people need to sleep okay fine
but then you kind of get more into the
FED policy and you get more into
interest rates and and you start to look
and you're like do we have free markets
in the United States
so I think we still do they're not as
free as they used to be and they're not
as free as they should be
the and Federal Reserve as you mentioned
it it no longer follows the the
Greenspan notion that we're going to Peg
the dollar to I think he essentially use
gold but but to a commodity with real
value to it and that was a great hedge
against inflation a great hedge against
expanding further than the economy could
have could really take it Milton
Friedman said it's better to have a
formula because humans will Tinker with
each Edge and most of the time they get
it wrong well you look back at the
history of the Federal Reserve most of
the time when you look backwards they
get it wrong
um they're smart then and the market
follows them and listens to them but
they they look and they see as we're
seeing now inflation oh it isn't
transitory it's real we got to do
something and so they start hiking
interest rates well chances are they're
going to hike them too far or too long
because the economy is going to turn and
correct itself before the Federal
Reserve does so that's an example where
we don't have a perfectly free market
and there's a cost to it yeah well even
if you just look over the last two years
I mean it it's um again hilarious to a
degree but sat on on the other side is
uh we created loose monetary policy
environment which we've been living in
for about a decade or so but we really
kind of ratcheted it up with zero
percent interest rates started printing
trillions and trillions of dollars uh
and they were still conducting
quantitative easing and had interest
rates at zero and we had seven percent
inflation in the United States of
America like talk about being behind the
curve
and then as we now have two consecutive
quarters of negative GDP growth which uh
is debatable I guess somehow that is at
a recession or not but I don't think the
FED uh for my knowledge has ever hiked
interest rates while in a recession and
so you start to think about these things
you say are we already behind the curve
and whether you think think we are or
we're not it Just begs the question of
like can humans actually understand
where we are currently given all the
data we have accurately analyze that and
then predict the future as well and keep
the price of money in an economy at the
correct level like that is a nearly
impossible task that's right
um and so you've got to build in
structures that that correct and along
the way and trust those structures
rather than human decision making there
was also just bad economics that came up
after the 08 crisis where they believed
it's okay to do unlimited quantitative
easing basically pumping up the money
supply is not going to cause inflation
well we now look at it and realize the
inflationary effect was being spread
across the world because the dollars the
world Reserve currency at some point
that limits reached I mean these rules
in economics are are immutable you can't
suddenly decide they've changed no
longer we won't have inflation anymore
when we pump up the money supply no it's
gonna maybe be absorbed for a while but
now we're starting to see the real
effects of it
some concern that that we've over
built the money supply so much that
there's going to be a crisis I don't
know the answer to that my hope is no
we'll be able to correct it and get back
on course and then have in Innovation
and the whole productivity of our
society catch up with that money supply
you think that's possible I think it is
possible really
um you don't have to convince me of this
because I don't think that they even
know that there's a problem let alone
that they're well yeah no I don't think
we've fully convinced the Federal
Reserve of this
um people who are objective are
realizing this new new economic theory
was a bunch of bunk and and they should
reject it handing out free money isn't a
good idea
it doesn't work I mean and it it
satisfied a political agenda right to to
keep everything going as long as you can
but eventually you got to pay the bill
it begs a question so if we just look at
this from uh kind of the most basic
analysis the Federal Reserve is supposed
to serve uh two core functions right
stable prices and as close to Full
Employment as they can get employment
and prices uh employment right now still
fairly low unemployment and appears to
be good now we can debate the finer
points of Labor Force participation and
all that but just put that aside for a
second and say okay the official number
is correct and we have low unemployment
prices are obviously not stable right uh
I am hard-pressed to find anyone who
believes that inflation is only eight to
nine percent and they don't think that
it hit double digits uh and is still
over double digits but let's take the
official number and say it's you know
eight point two eight point three
percent
what I think it begs the question of is
like the Federal Reserve is supposed to
be independent and now what we saw when
uh Trump was President he was literally
tweeting with her anxiety hey devalue
the currency and and you know you would
have thought that he was an economist uh
uh uh maybe a a uh armchair Economist
but saying hey we need to change the
value of our money because of all these
growth initiatives
when we got through uh some of the
pandemic stuff we also saw a lot of
politicians not the president uh across
Isles and then now with the new
Administration advocating in various
different ways for certain monetary
policy and so is the Federal Reserve an
independent organization today or should
we never expect it to actually be
independent and we should understand
that it operates within a larger machine
of the political system I think the
latter the the it's a it's too much to
expect it to be truly independent and
they they when they created it tried to
build in the mechanisms by having the
banks be the ultimate owners rather than
the government
um but they're and as soon as you get
anybody that's weak and I think Powell
is weak in terms of resisting political
pressure
that the constituency becomes both
Washington and then the the market
and ultimately
the there is a governor on them and that
the bank ownership will dictate that
what interest rate they are because
Banks aren't going to lend below the
inflation rate forever right so so there
are governing principles that come in
and force them to do the right thing but
it's it's in some ways better than the
White House controlling the money supply
agree and whether it's Republican or
Democrat right so it's it's better than
the alternative but it it's not perfect
and it's not going to be totally
independent
um the the key thing I I think is to
move in the direction that Friedman
urged us for decades
put in more formulas that are tested
over time so that you don't have that
human in discretion or you limit the
human discretion because humans
inherently are political they're gonna
they've got some audience they're
playing too whether it's it's their
friends on Wall Street whether it's the
politicians whether it's the public at
large you know if the last thing in the
world the Federal Reserve decision
makers want is to have the media turn
them into evil agents that are
destroying our economy right because
then everybody will hate them yeah and
it's just human nature you don't want to
be in that position yeah but if we set
up these formulas where they they can
say these are proven over time it can be
painful at times when we've got to do
the correction but we're going to rely
on the formula then then it takes some
of that human Frailty out of it yeah it
did feel a little bit at one point uh
Joe Biden called Jerome Powell to his
office and they had a meeting
and I said at the time I said this feels
like getting called to the principal's
office right right and you know of
course uh they're never going to
explicitly say You must do actually you
must do why but it did feel a little bit
like I'm checking in here uh inflation's
high is not coming down what the hell's
going on over there
um and you know publicly they'll say all
the right things of uh the Federal
Reserve is going to do what they believe
uh best
um but but it's hard to uh kind of
balance that thought process with with
fed Reserve Presidents Day trading
assets that the FED is buying themselves
we have politicians who seem to be very
involved
um and then you get into like
talking about this stuff and I think
that's actually the most interesting
part of the Federal Reserve right now is
they used to never talk right they never
did uh press conferences many young
people don't know that that like this is
the new phenomenon uh in the grand
scheme of things of the whole idea of
having the press conferences and having
trillions of dollars basically waiting
on every breath of you know what is
Powell gonna say or whatever
but then they just say crazy things like
inflation is transitory or the president
was recently interviewed and he's like
ah inflation was only up just an inch
yeah right month to month just an inch
and it's like uh okay yeah but when it's
at eight percent that inch matters so
like how do you guys just think about
like okay there's something that's
happening but then there's a way to talk
about it and and I think that actually
it feels like most people are uh they're
willing to deal with what's happening
because they can't change it
but they do feel like the way these
things are talked about that's where
people are getting upset because they
feel like they're either being misled uh
uh people who are talking or
capitalizing on the lack of financial
education or the understanding of the
Nuance of markets like how do you guys
think about well and and the the huge
risk in the economy that when they talk
one they always hedge everything right
they're like lawyers or politicians
um which I'm both people accuse me of
doing the same thing but they hedged and
just in case they're wrong well recently
Powell sent out a message that okay
we're we don't have a definite plan
going forward well the market for two or
three weeks took that as oh they're not
going to do any more interest rate hikes
by the way I'll give credit to my guys
at Morgan Stanley I called him and said
what are you guys doing and they said
we're ignoring that because they are
going to have another interest rate hike
and so we're steady as it goes David and
and they were right because about three
Weeks Later the whole Market realized oh
that isn't what Powell meant he just
meant they weren't definitely having a
plan you know three quarters out but yes
they're steady as we go and and raising
interest rates until we get it to the
right level and so you had three weeks
where everybody was using bad
information
um and if whereas if you say nothing
then people will look at what are the
market indicators what's the we're not
going to try to second guess what
government's going to do to change our
lives
um also back to the Federal Reserve I
think it's a mistake to have that dual
Mission and now the progressives are
arguing for a three-part Mission the
third part being kind of woke Capital
um but it would be they would be much
better suited if they focused on on the
monetary Supply and the inflation and
they left the employment number to the
policy site to Congress and the
president to do policies that will allow
the economy to thrive because when you
have the Federal Reserve driving that it
creates too much of an incentive like
we've had over the last 10 years to have
lower interest rates than what should be
there in the market yeah how do you
balance the idea that the Federal
Reserve now you know pretty much since
November of 2021 has been talking about
uh uh tighter Financial conditions we're
going to raise interest rates we're
eventually going to do quantitative
tightening and and we're going to kind
of turn this big cruise ship and and
we're gonna get on the right track
remains to be seen whether they will be
successful or not uh I tend to think
that it may be hard for them to get
inflation down if they can't raise the
interest rate above inflation without
bankrupting the United States and so you
get some complexity there but at the
same time that they're attempting
tighter Financial conditions
politicians are still spending like
they're drunk right right
it's like every week we're sending you
know weapons and money and all this
other stuff to other countries
I mean like how do you balance it
because it literally feels like these
two strategies are completely at odds
with each other like we have
inflationary pressures by continuing to
conduct all sorts of uh fiscal policy
and and and geopolitical uh uh
essentially
uh I don't use the word bribery but like
it feels very kind of weird while at the
same time fed's like hey we got to stop
this and we got to create tender
Financial conditions so this is where
elections come in the Federal Reserve
isn't elected they're going to continue
past these November elections but but
we're going to have a referendum and the
Public's going to say do we want more of
this profitly good spending by both
Republicans and Democrats or do we want
to tighten the belt and get a a grip on
this inflation and the poll numbers we
we pull three times a week in different
races around the country every time the
number one issue people are concerned
about is that inflation and the cost of
living and how it's hurting their
ability their their real income and so
that's that's going to be on the ballot
and the politicians
both sides are continuing with their
current strategies Republicans saying no
we're not going to go all the way that
that the Democrats want to do but we
like some spending so we'll go with the
ones we we like
um and repo and Democrats saying no we
we need to just spend more and that'll
solve the problems that we have
um and the voters are going to decide
which path do we want to go on and then
afterwards the politicians wake up and
say oh okay the public mandates this I
got to be careful and don't get
crosswise with that public mandate you
you've mentioned a couple times that
Republicans and Democrats both do it
which I think will surprise people to
hear you say that uh given the
organization that you run generally
supports uh Republican candidates yeah
why do you say that both of them do it
yeah let me let me um set the table for
that what we try to do is support
candidates who are for free markets and
limited government the Republican party
is generally more in favor of that so
the candidates we pick are Republicans
we spend a lot in the primaries to pick
which Republicans will go forward on
that but it's true you look at the
spending you know president Trump
advocated all sorts of deficit spending
the Senate Mitch McConnell and the
appropriators they love to spend money
and and they would argue that's good
politics you never lose if you spend
money and the problem is we now see this
as you pointed out 140 percent debt to
to
GDP ratio
that it's putting the country on the
brink of of a real financial disaster
and
I also think it's an Integrity question
every single one of those Republicans
goes home and tells their constituents
I'm going to stop this government
wasteful spending we're going to get a
control on this we're going to get to a
balanced budget
um and and then they go back to
Washington and they vote on all of these
huge bills and if they feel bad about it
then McConnell comes out and says oh
well we can't shut down the government
so we got to spend for a vote for this
huge spending bill that I know you
haven't read because we just wrote it
and showed it to you 24 hours and it's 7
000 Pages it's 7 000 pages long all
these ridiculous spending as we were
talking about earlier you know studies
on the effect of marijuana the bridges
to Nowhere the mating habits of bees you
know all this ridiculous stuff that they
load into there so I've heard uh an
argument I one time said to somebody
like all the pork right all the uh um uh
essentially buying votes right you've
done in a politically acceptable way and
a very well known investor uh who's at
lunch with me said no we need that I
said what do you mean he goes it would
be a deadlock we would get nothing done
unless there was the ability to put some
of this stuff in and so he was making
the argument that like look nobody likes
it but it's a necessary uh side effect
in order to get things done do you agree
with that or disagree with that well the
question I would ask is get what what
are they getting done and is that a good
thing or a bad thing so I don't want to
just get things done because oftentimes
in Washington it's actually a bad thing
um I I get the theory that it greases
the skids and and gets the votes but
what it's getting the votes for are
these huge deficit spending with
absolutely no restraint and very little
oversight of where's all this money
going how's it being spent what's
happening to it so to me the ultimate
response to that is I don't want to just
get anything done I want to get the
right thing it doesn't yeah
um the the two data points that just
stick out to me as kind of wild over uh
the economic markets of the last couple
years is uh first the Federal Reserves
balance sheet 10x it was a 10 bagger
right and uh uh we jokingly uh for a
while had like a countdown like hey when
are we gonna hit the 10x right because
we were we were kind of like around 900
billion or so when the OA crisis
happened and uh it took 14 years you
know start at the bottom but now we're
here and and uh and we got the 10x
increase which is insane totally
obviously uh do you think I guess on the
first point do you think that that can
come back down do you think we'll ever
see uh instead of having eight and a
half nine nine and a half trillion
dollars could we get it under five could
we get it under a trillion again how do
you think about that
yes it's possible but it'll take
leadership that's willing to to break
some eggs and and change the way things
are done in Washington what I see
Americans
wanting is that type of leadership
um now I think it's important to discern
who that is what they're going to do
what do they have good judgment but it
is possible if you disrupt the system
the way it is going now and you have
discipline
um well honestly I think it will take
somebody who's willing to to basically
tell the political leaders on their side
of The Ledger I am willing to to disrupt
close things and until we get it right
I'm not going to just accept this 78 000
page bill that you're writing
um and use the majority that he'd have
in his party to change the system in the
Federal Reserve side I think
it'll take a new Personnel in some ways
somebody who understands the the real
way that monetary policy should work and
the discipline not not immediately to
totally disrupt things but put us on a
path to say we're going to reduce this
systematically over time when we think
of the second data point that sticks out
in my head is uh in 2020 we bail out the
airline industry and when we build out
the airline industry there was two key
components to it the first was the
airlines for basically a decade had
spent a lot of their free cash flow
doing stock BuyBacks and we can you know
tons of incentives that that maybe
misaligned with shareholders and all
stuff basically they got to a point
which was a catastrophic external shock
to their business but they didn't have
the money they could not survive and uh
it's easy to armchair quarterback and
say hey what were you doing for the last
decade right why don't you have that
cash uh but that's the situation they're
in but it
time I remember explicitly calling out
saying wait a minute
they're not going to the equity markets
they're not going to the debt markets
they ran to the government on day one
and said you have to bail us out we we
are too big to fail essentially right
you have to bail us out and what struck
me was they've identified the sucker in
the room yeah they know that they're
going to get a deal from the US
government that nobody on the equity or
debt Market will give to them and sure
enough there was I think 25 billion
dollars was kind of the initial uh kind
of bailout I think there was a second
leg to it at some point
um and the money was given and about
two-thirds of it no equity so there's no
nationalization of any of these uh and
there was no intention to pay back the
money it was just literally we're just
gonna hand you tens of billions of
dollars and like you know
yeah keep running the planes
how do we run a government or how do we
deal with the next Crisis if that now
has become the Playbook right right the
banks did it now the airlines do it like
who's next so exactly and you you get
all of the bad side of the risk reward
equation right
um You you don't you're not punished for
taking a risk when it fails and I'm a
big believer this is going to sound
harsh but I'm a big believer in let
bankruptcy work and keep the airlines
going but Wipe Out the equity and for
people who invested in management that
made bad decisions they didn't reserve
the capital for that type of a
contingency and don't reward that
because for two reasons one it's not
fair right why should every worker in
America pay money to reward these people
for making bad decisions but second it
creates an incentive for the next time
to make the same bad decision
um you know they they realized we can go
back to the ATM that is the government
in Washington and that'll cover any
downside to the risks so let's take
stupid risks
um it it the key to free markets working
is the discipline of that risk reward
you failed you lose you succeed you get
rewarded and when we have the government
come in and say we're only going to let
you get rewarded and we'll cover your
backside well that sounds nice but it
creates all sorts of wrong incentives
yeah that the removing risk from markets
incentivizes some pretty ridiculous
Behavior right right because we do you
go and take as much risk as possible
there's no punishment we've seen it over
and over again this is maybe a little
bit old history but there was a whole
um Savings and Loan crisis where the
government
basically guaranteed they'd cover the
downside of of loan defaults and
incentivize these Savings and Loans to
make very risky out of the normal
banking decisions on loans they make
well soon pretty soon they were all
bankrupt and the government was having
to come in and take them over shocking
yeah right if you say to somebody we
will uh remove the risk they will take
as much risk as they possibly can
because there's no punishment and and
you get a much higher fee for that risk
right so it looks like your your bottom
line is you're making tons of money but
what happens is when it all the risk
doesn't work then that they pocket the
money and the government pays for it
yeah the Club for Growth one of the the
key ideas is this idea of reducing the
size and scope of the federal government
uh you have a unique perspective you
actually were in the government uh you
served as an elected official uh what
was it like decades ago right compared
to today when you actually were serving
in the government what was the size of
the government how has it changed over
time this episode is brought to you by
eight sleep good sleep is a game changer
and the eight sleep pod is the best
sleep machine I sleep on it every single
night a great night of sleep allows you
to be healthier be more arrested and
have more energy throughout the day and
on the brand new eight sleep pod 3 you
can sleep as cold as 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself in each sleep you
can go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep yeah and and
I started shortly after Law School in
the regular Administration first there
was actual genuine bipartisanship still
at that point and I think part of it was
um the Democrat Party was pretty secure
in controlling Congress and the
Republican Party most of the time was
able to win the White House so you had a
balance of power and they worked
together
but there was also an Integrity that
that Reagan himself brought to it which
is when I say something to the voters to
the American people
my government's going to do that
too many times today politicians
separate
say campaigning what they tell people
and then what they do and they cynically
think well nobody will figure out that I
didn't keep my promises
what's happened over time but we still
believed in the American government back
when I was growing up at that point in
time today people see that and I was
going to say they're cynical they're
actually perceptive that they've we've
got a bunch of people who tell us one
thing and then do the opposite when we
give them power and they don't know who
to trust and that
perception leads them to distrust
government which is bad for our society
we want government should have as its
number one priority building that trust
and confidence of the American people
I'm a big believer that power in our
system is with the people
the government of the People by the
people for the people as Lincoln
famously said and that power is Lent to
Congress lent to the president lent to
the government in Washington to do good
things for society but if the government
becomes self-interested or lacks
integrity and lies to people about what
they're really doing then the people
have
eventually become dissatisfied to become
disgruntled and eventually I think
they'll replace them and
hopefully that replacement is through a
peaceful democratic election process if
they continue to get frustrated about
that then then there'll be people who
come up and say well we gotta have
Revolution essentially I don't want that
I think we're prosperous when we have
this stable Democratic process but that
requires integrity and and that's one of
the bigger differences that I see also
the the scope of what government
believes they can get in involved in
back then the key mission was fighting
communism in in the Soviet Union right
and
um keeping the prosperity in our country
so that everybody had a chance at the
American dream you know you worked hard
and you succeeded your kids could go to
college and have an even better job than
you that that was what everybody felt
knew experienced in their life at post
World War II and and believed was the
future today
you see that governments thinking oh
well we want to tell people you know how
they behave we want to tell people
um what products they can buy and
shouldn't buy
um I noticed the the bank Regulators are
starting to tell Banks well some
products that are legal we don't really
like so don't lend them money that's a
huge intrusion into everybody's personal
choice about how they spend their money
and what they do in life if it's a legal
activity the government should be
neutral about that and that a decision
that's gradually crept in that it's okay
for us to have the government tell
people how they should live their lives
rather than create a system of
opportunity where they make the choices
and that's a big change
I read an interesting book it's actually
been out now for probably over 10 years
by Charles Murray uh coming apart and he
described how there are increasingly
separation between the elite
college-educated citizens and the rest
of the country when I grew up as a
little town in Indiana and there there
were no fences there were a couple
wealthy families that lived in the same
neighborhoods as everybody else there
were foundries that people worked and
and spent their lives doing that and
going and sending their kids to school
there was this sense that we were all
one Community today you look and you see
and he pointed out that the wealthy
college educated folks live in certain
neighborhoods but are not distributed
around the country anymore and typically
those neighborhoods are fenced off and
with the gate and they're isolated and
they have power and are using that power
to benefit themselves and the rest of
the country's feeling like you know
what's happening to us we're being left
out yeah that sort of social divide I
think is is a very problematic for us
um you see it people are surprised by it
in elections When Donald Trump harnessed
a lot of that discontent upon the broad
public and the elites were shocked on
the day after the election that someone
like that could get elected and but they
didn't wake up and say oh maybe we need
to rethink how we do things and and have
a better more united society and that
not everybody is like us
um that hasn't happened and and I think
one of the things we look for are
political leaders who are aware of that
and and want to lead for everybody yeah
one of the things I'm fascinated by is
uh although I consider myself an
independent and generally would have
been very disinterested in in politics
and a lot of what I would consider the
day-to-day kind of posturing and
campaigning and all this stuff uh as you
get older as you learn more you realize
it is uh part of every aspect of society
uh but in today a society everything
seems to get politicized even faster the
feedback loop happens quicker and
quicker and I recently heard
um uh Peter Thiel he gave a speech at a
conference and he was like you know the
old adage of the Republican party is for
the middle class and the Democratic
party is for everybody else
which was interesting because I think if
you went and you talked to many people
in the finance world or who pay
attention to economics they would say
hey America is losing the middle class
there's basically this bifurcation you
see it in the wealth inequality you see
it in kind of all these things where
we're getting some people are getting
very very wealthy and then some people
are getting into more and more dire
financial situation so how do you guys
think of like the different economic
classes and then how that intersects
with uh um political parties and kind of
like where we are as a society right now
so the the old thinking was the the
Republicans for were business and the
rich the Democrats were For the Working
Man and and that that was the post-world
War II now I think it it's like a
barbell the Democratic party is actually
the party of the Rich and Elite and at
the other end though the folks are on
welfare the dependent classes and the
Republican party is that middle class
you know from industrial workers all the
way up to to small businessmen and folks
who are in that you know upper middle
class not quite Rich group group they
tend to identify more with the
Republican on economic issues
the problem with the way the Democrats
approach it is there's this huge
incentive to keep that poor dependent
class on welfare right you see it in
education policy where they you have
Elite schools you have either
neighborhoods with really good Public
Schools or private schools that they
send their kids to and they throw money
at these poor inner city schools but
they don't do anything to change it
where it's safer for the kids and they
actually get a good education so poor
typically minorities blacks Latinos
their families are stuck in these public
schools that are supposed to be the
pathway to opportunity but in fact keep
them down on the farm if you will and
that nobody will admit that's what
they're doing but our whole welfare
system is created around the notion of
we want you to be dependent we're going
to keep you in the system because
otherwise you'll be pennilessed out on
the streets rather than a system that
says we'll be there as a safety net if
something happens and you're not working
well but we're going to channel you into
that broad middle class mainstream where
you can take care of yourself have your
own apartment have your own house have
your job and your kids can go to a good
school that used to be the dream that
America had for the poor that they could
Escape poverty and become in that now
because the politics are for the
Democrats rich or poor dependent people
on welfare they can't afford to let too
many of them Escape because then they
don't have enough votes to win the
elections yeah I mean it that that's the
truth of the matter that nobody will
admit in Washington so let me ask uh uh
there's a lot to unpack here right I
think there's a lot of people who will
listen to this and some people will not
read yup he nailed it like that that's
exactly what happens and then there's
other people say this guy's nuts like
what is he talking about and I already
envisioned uh uh uh the uh the nice
conversation yeah that happens uh with a
framework like that I guess the first
thing is
um how much of that is intentional what
you just laid out is intentional versus
it is a byproduct of people who are well
intentioned trying to do good and they
just don't realize that they're side
effects that that end up happening like
is it a a evil plan maybe it's like the
extreme way to describe it like there's
some intentionality there or is it no
they're they're trying to do the right
thing as a system and we just haven't
figured out the right way to do it uh
and so we have these side effects so I I
think initially it starts with the
unintended consequences okay but when
they reject any reform that would change
the system then I think it becomes
intentional we want to keep it the way
it is and and again you see this in
education the teachers union absolutely
rejects any notion that we're going to
have choice about what schools their
kids go to describe a little bit about
school choice because I know you need to
spend a lot of time on this the core
value there is that the parent should be
involved in the spending of the money of
where their kids go to school so they
can look at the school and say yeah this
is the right fit for my child or no this
is a dangerous school I want to send
them to another safer school now a lot
of times we used to think of it okay
it's taking kids out of the public
schools I think of it as also putting
parents in control of the public school
money okay so so this is a a idea that I
think a lot of people uh they never even
heard of right choice right but right
now the way that the system works is
where you live pretty much determines
where you go to school like when I when
uh I was in elementary middle in high
school people would uh they would move
they would I remember uh I went to
school with a kid in third or fourth
grade and like they were were using
somebody like a relative's address
there's all these things that happened
Sports specifically it becomes a big
incentive yeah all that what you're
talking about is maybe those lines
shouldn't just be drawn based on where
you live but there should be more
control given to the parents so how
would that work and and let's say I had
a middle school or a high school student
what does that look like uh in terms of
what I'm able to choose and we we label
it school freedom I think because it
gives the parents the freedom to have
the best education for their kids
there's a classic way it would be is If
the parents are in a neighborhood and
the school is failing they're not
teaching the kids it might be dangerous
because there's no discipline they have
the ability to take some of that money
and send their kids maybe to a parochial
school that's there in the same
neighborhood stupid question so you get
competing schools so stupid question is
when you say some of that money there's
like a budget that each parent is given
or how does that yeah um they call it a
scholarship typically and let's say in a
lot of urban areas it's 15 to twenty
thousand dollars a kid that's being
spent yeah is huge and we're getting
very little for it it's one of the
biggest each kid that goes to school
there's about let's just round up and
say twenty thousand dollars or so being
spent for that kid to go to school that
for a year yeah and now it would say
well wait maybe if the parent doesn't
want the kid to go there and the kid
might not even want to go there is there
a way to redirect those funds to allow
them to go somewhere that's right and
typically what what the proposals are is
say okay let's take maybe 10 000 of that
they can use it for tuition somewhere
else and another five thousand the new
plan is another five thousand that will
put in a savings account so they can pay
for college so all of a sudden these
these poor families have a chance to get
a better education and funding for
college and that leaves the other five
thousand that stays there in the public
school and they don't have a kid that
they're worried about so it it's extra
money for them essentially
um that's the typical proposal of how it
would work I would add on to that that
if the parent decides to stay in that
public school the school has to get the
parent to sign off on the money going
there think about it if if a bureaucrat
in the school
doesn't want parents in his office
complaining about you know their kid
getting beaten up and nobody's doing
anything about the gang he'd prefer to
keep them out of the school well if
those parents get to sign off whether he
gets his money or not he's going to pay
attention to him I mean it changes the
whole dynamic well in some way the
parent is and the child but is the
customer yeah right and you become the
customer when they control the money yes
and we saw this up in Virginia it was a
Suburban County they they were frankly
terrible about disciplining some of the
things going on in the T with the
teachers abusing the kids and the
parents got really upset and they locked
them out and actually had some of them
arrested when they tried to go to the
school board and complain this was the
big incident that Glenn yunkin said no
parents need to be involved in education
he won the Virginia governorship on that
principle if the dynamic had been there
where that school board knew this whole
block of parents can take their money
and go somewhere else I tell you they
never would have done that they would
have never tried to hide from those
customers and it changed the dynamic now
that school freedom I think is probably
the biggest way we can change life for
Middle America and and folks who are
underprivileged and poor
if we flip the other side of the table
what would the counter argument to this
be like the people who say uh you know
sounds awesome no right what is their
logic as to why they don't want this to
happen typically and it's the teachers
unions that come out with this they say
oh you're stealing money from the public
schools that that's the counter argument
um and
in the past people heard that and said
well no I like my public school it was a
great experience that's where I went I
had to go now interestingly covet
changed a lot of that parents looked in
and saw what was going on in the public
school and they weren't that happy with
it especially when they said your kids
can't come back or they got to wear a
mask and the parents didn't want that so
covid kind of blew open the the the
system in education where parents now
have a much better idea of what's going
on and that old argument that hey you're
taking money away from us doesn't carry
water anymore we see we see it in polls
where we ask people would you want to
have this type of school freedom in your
school system it used to be less than 50
now it's close to 60 percent of
Americans say yes that would be a good
reform so the trend is more and more
people are opening uh are open to this
idea and your hypothesis is it's because
they saw what was going on in the
schools during covet and then on time
from that
um I think it's the civil rights
movement of the of the Next Generation
interesting because if you look at where
poor schools are they're almost always
disproportionately black Hispanic
minority school systems and if we can
change the way they deliver education
for those families it's a huge step up
it's a huge equalizer in our society and
and I think honestly I think it's not
right if we don't do it yeah it feels
like
um education generally across political
aisles across countries across ethnic
lines all these different ways you can
cut societies uh education is seen as an
equalizer right and and the more
educated you are the better kind of
trajectory you have in life the more
likely you are to change your family
lineage or kind of generations of your
past family and improve that of your
Generations
what always has shocked me I think is
how many parents don't have the
opportunity to even worry about what's
going on inside of the school because
they have guys go to work or they've got
other you know there's just life going
on there's actually a lot of students
are working and yes and so I guess a
piece of this is covet obviously had
parents and students both at home right
and so there is this like almost
Collision of hey I'm on my computer uh
trying to do whatever I can from home
but like what are you doing right right
what are they teaching you yeah what's
going on I don't sound right to me
um but but it also brings this question
of like education not just for uh
children there's also education of young
adults of adults themselves the internet
obviously has broken down many of these
large institutions it is kind of exposed
you know all these things in society
that I think people previously held is
true and maybe now a question
but that also feels like there's this
whole political movement around being
willing to go and find the answers yeah
I think when I grew up it was always
just like what we were told I don't
think people like a lot of people kind
of questioned it
and that feels like over the last 20 or
30 years that's changed significantly to
now maybe the default isn't I don't
believe that
but there's definitely like maybe right
or it is the response when they're told
something like sure maybe that's true
maybe it's not like let me go look and
do you guys see that in the work you do
oh yeah totally that that people are
um one they're they're willing to go
Google something right and say is that
right
um so you you and I think that'll be a
great antiseptic for politics because we
politicians became kind of cynical you
know voters aren't paying attention I
can do whatever I want after I'm elected
but also in the campaigns and sadly
right now I'd say we're in a really bad
place where
um and it's part of our ethic of First
Amendment let everything be out there
there used to be yeah you were earlier
experiences in politics when I ran for
congress back in the 90s there was an
ethic that you should tell the truth you
can have a strong message you can attack
your opponent you can but it needs to be
truthful
the the they wouldn't stop you from
saying on something untrue but you'd get
called on it and the public didn't like
it today I look at ads that are just
made up
um and and people say we'll we'll throw
[ __ ] on the wall and see what sticks
um or just one side yeah I think it is
both sides though I noticed the ones on
the other side but I think unfortunately
it is on both sides it's more of a state
of politics than it is
I'm a big believer in the First
Amendment free speech so I don't think
government should come in and police it
but but I would like our society to go
back and say hey we googled that and
that's just not true and have that
become then a response because the
politicians will then be stuck and
they'll they won't do it yeah when I
think of
um I say both sides and I always catch
myself I say well actually uh yes those
are the two dominant sides there is uh
libertarian party Andrew Yang has the
forward party which you know small and I
think he hopes and aspires for too much
bigger
um how do you look at the kind of
landscape today is it really just
Republicans Democrats and that's all
that kind of matters could a Libertarian
candidate become president or uh win as
a governor of a state what about some of
these new you know ideas around
political parties like how do you guys
evaluate uh maybe outside of just
Republican and Democrat
um what we see over and over again is
the that dual Democrat Republican
partisanship is really very strong
um you you get some of the outlier
parties
and the way our system works is like the
Republican party has an incentive to be
more libertarian to bring them back into
the party the Democrat Party has an
incentive to be more right now more
socialist to bring the progressives in
I'm hoping they move in the let's be
more
um moderate more Pro business to bring
in the Andrew yangs that are more
moderate in the way they approach things
um and the two parties form these
coalitions that that bring in the the
third parties
the
there's a risk and and some people have
projected that one or the two parties
will blow up that the stress with those
different elements is will be too great
The the true progressives are totally
adverse to the old traditional Democrat
that was
pro-economy pro-america but for a more
liberal bigger government the
progressives think they're the enemy we
saw it in the Republicans with the Tea
Party viewing the old establishment
Republicans as the enemy and their
stresses that in each of them that could
blow up and then you could have a third
party if that happened
typically in our history I mean the big
time that happened was pre-civil war
over the question of slavery right the
the traditional parties blew up you had
a new Republican anti-slavery Party
come from nowhere and and then elect
President Lincoln eventually
um it's hard it's harder to see that
today yeah when I think of the political
parties there's uh kind of two different
battles I'll call them
um there is uh the rise of the oldest
generation so you have Donald Trump
versus Joe Biden right and that's kind
of
um I don't know over 70 and uh a very
unique uh uh kind of uh facing off of
two candidates if you go down a
generation or two you then have Ron
DeSantis and Gavin Newsom and I think
that whether correctly or not there
seems to be uh in the Twitter verse and
and among the tech community and folks
like that A belief that Joe Biden and
Donald Trump will not run for president
in 2024 uh even if they try they won't
actually be the nominees and I don't
know if that's true or not uh we can't
predict the future
um let's hold constant for a second that
neither one of the over 70 candidates
end up uh participating
the I think default or the consensus
right now would be hey it's probably
like a Gavin Newsom and Ron DeSantis if
it's not them it's people like them how
do you evaluate where on the the
national level
um people kind of see these two types of
candidates because it does feel like you
know California's going One Direction
Florida's going a different uh there's
there's differences in economic policies
there's differences in social policies
and rather than like what's right what's
not right like it just feels like
they're pulling away from each other
yeah and that usually you know plays out
how yeah so uh both of them are playing
to their base the the strong beliefs in
that and I'll full disclosure I'm a huge
Rhonda Santa's fan okay so I'll try to
be objective you would have shocked me
if you said that you were a Gavin
Newsome fan but okay no exactly but but
I think what DeSantis is is showing
leadership in consolidating the
conservative base on economic Comics
he's and he's has a lot to brag about
with Florida that yeah our economic
theory works it's good for people we
survive coven we came out faster
but also on social issues that he's
gonna he's saying we're not gonna kind
of subsidize the woke capitalism anymore
you can do what you want but we're not
going to subsidize it and pay for it
um Newsome is Basis is the progressive
wing of the Democrat Party I've seen
polling in different races that in their
primaries progressives win
um in the general election I think
they're going to lose because people
will look at what's happened in
California and say okay which future is
better for us one where they've embraced
fully both the woke culture government
control progressive taxation and our
people rising there or are people
leaving because and and they're going to
say Florida embrace the opposite it's
successful people are moving there and
everyone in the middle is going to say I
want to be in an environment like
Florida whether they like Florida or not
rather than California both are
beautiful full places places you'd want
to live but the whole policy and
economics is in such contrast California
is failing Florida is succeeding so
really it's interesting because they're
both employing the same political
strategy play to the base go say the
things that uh hopefully they believe
but but they're saying the things that
they know those bases want to hear and
and are aligned with and really what I
think you're outlining is less about uh
individual candidates and this is more
of like an ideological election right
it's kind of hey there are two Futures
choose which one and the expectation
would be uh maybe the people in those
parties will vote along their parties
and the ideologies that they've
previously uh kind of indicated
but it's this middle group now that is
saying oh there's like a black and white
like there's you know left the right and
there isn't really uh maybe room or or
interest in some sort of Centrist type
uh candidate
um today's episode is brought to you by
Alto I all right have you wanted to buy
Bitcoin or over 200 other
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account well now you can with Alto Ira
they allow you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies in a tax advantage way
there's no account or setup fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to Alto ira.com to get started
Alto ira.com pomp invest in Bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies in your retirement
account and get all the tax advantages
while still holding digital currencies
Alto ira.com
it'll the the candidate that shows
they'll work with this interest is most
likely to win interesting run to Samus
it is really strong on protecting the
Everglades for for example and standing
up to Big Sugar here in Florida that won
him a lot of Kudos with more independent
voters who care about the environment
and and that was important to them if he
finds some things like that nationally
to carry forward I think he locks down
that independent voter Newsome is is
stuck with his record in California
where they they basically rejected the
more Centrist approach went for the most
radical answers in a whole bunch of
areas whether it's the environment taxes
the economy
um I mean people are making fun of them
now where they're saying we're going to
eliminate gasoline driven cars go to
electric cars but by the way don't
recharge them because we also don't like
power plants so we don't have any
electricity I mean it it part of it is
what works right now the other thing
that that is a factor in American
politics is style
and you've got competing Style there you
know Newsome is smooth glamorous kind of
Hollywood Central Casting DeSantis is
more Rough Around the Edges coming out
of a military background and a football
player now he went to an Ivy League
school he's and he's super smart but his
style is more uh kind of everyday man
style
if it were following Trump I would worry
that there would be this appeal for the
Hollywood glamor but following Biden I
think people are gonna
look and wanna more DeSantis type I want
somebody that's more relatable to me
it's fascinating to think about uh even
the style is uh I don't say Polar
Opposites right they both wear shoes
right or whatever right but but uh for
within the arena of politics it is
pretty different I never thought of it
that way but but that is fascinating
yeah
when
um when we think of uh Trump and Biden
uh
they're over 70. uh I think I believe
Joe Biden is the oldest president uh
oldest uh ever sitting president but I
saw a statistic recently which was in
the 90s if I remember the data correctly
five percent of uh congressmen and women
were over the age of 70. this is now I
think it's 24 percent
yeah and so in a 20 25 year period we
have essentially you know four to five
axed the number of over 70 within
Congress
is that good for America
um no it's it's time for us to turn over
to the next Generation
Um I we do a lot of Elections and
support candidates some of the ones that
I'm super excited about your listeners
probably will never heard of but but
they will because they're the Next
Generation there's a guy in North
Carolina Beau Heinz who actually day
traded cryptocurrency in college studied
crypto law in law school and there's 27
super smart young leader there's new
people Anna Luna here in Florida who
understands and and is engaged in social
media the next generation's way of
communicating Carolyn Levitt up in New
Hampshire is a young 25 year old who
they're going to see in this new
Congress these freshmen who will go on
and rise in leadership somebody here's
25 right let's use it super young 25
scenes super young 75 seem super old
right it's kind of like the thing so do
we get a full rotation back to like 20
no there's plenty of folks in between
that are going to be good solid they've
been 10 years in some other profession
or local government in the 30s and 40s
as well but these these young guys that
I'm telling you about like Caroline
Chiefs worked at the White House so even
though she's that young she's seen the
center of power in Washington knows the
problems that come along with it and how
to work with it
um I'm very optimistic about the future
and the type of leaderships we have
honestly as I observe on the Democrat
side Nancy Pelosi is I think going to
finish up this term as her last time in
leadership my prediction is Republicans
are going to get the house it certainly
looks that way in all the polling
um and that that's going to give the
Democrat Party an opportunity to decide
for themselves what's our leadership
look like do we go next in line line
who's also 70 or next six couple people
yeah or do we move to the next are our
younger folks and they've got some
really talented people uh the the guy
who's the head of the black
um caucus in the Democrat Party Hakeem
Jeffries is both a progressive and he
can work with them but also Pro economy
pro-growth
um smart articulate you know I'm sure he
and I would vote opposite on lots of
things but but I like to see leaders in
the other party who are committed to the
country and and good people and and I
think the Democrats will have a chance
also to pass the Baton down to the Next
Generation yeah and when you think of
some of the topics that people care
about
um obviously the economy and inflation
and stuff like that but a lot of people
listen to this care about Bitcoin right
they care about Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and uh um kind of all
these new technologies and stuff like
that maybe a place to start would just
be like what is the level of Education
you think or even maybe interest in the
various political candidates or people
sitting in political office is this
something where the public perception is
incorrect and actually all of these
individuals uh you know hold Bitcoin
they're excited about it and they know
everything or is there still a long road
there like how do you kind of analyze uh
maybe that education level yeah let me
let me start by saying Club for Growth
is over the last two years totally
embraced Bitcoin and cryptocurrency as
the future and we see tremendous
opportunities I I think it's the next
wave and if you want to call it
technology and Innovation it's also a
disrupter of the status quo in various
areas and therefore a huge
development for individual freedom and
we embrace it it fits completely with
our efforts we're the largest political
group that is pro Freedom pro-free
market and we've embraced it or moving
in
but to your question what's the status
where are we at where what's the status
quo in the lay of the land most members
of Congress two years ago wouldn't
scratch their head what are you talking
about today would say oh yeah I've heard
about Bitcoin yeah it sounds good the
older ones would say now I don't know it
might be tulip bulbs you know the old
arguments against it that that were out
there in that older generation of
investors
um what that tells me is we need to do
education in those political leaders
this year I went came down to the
Bitcoin conference here in Miami
fascinating and what I saw was a
community of people who were diverse all
over the country various backgrounds
their whole lives were committed to the
beliefs that I care about individual
Freedom autonomy making their way and
they were totally not political right if
you talk to them a little bit about
politics it was well I hope we can be
bipartisan about this
um what's happened is with the
infrastructure Bill passing you know
sadly Republicans wrote it this
empowerment of IRS to require more
disclosure government is coming into
that community and my message to
bitcoiners and folks who are invested in
it is it's great that you've thrived
outside of politics but your enemies are
going to engage in politics I saw the
other day that that the guys who made
money on Ripple have invested heavily in
a couple of environmental radical
organizations to attack Bitcoin mining
that's the way I call it crony
capitalism it we've seen it over and
over again in Industries they use the
political process to tear apart their
adversaries and to try to get a business
Advantage so it's coming what we need to
do is not only educate members in all
both parties but identify Champions
people who really understand it see the
value of it and will defend It Against
The Regulators against the other
politicians we've found a few of those
that we're supporting on the Republican
side Ted Budd who's running in North
Carolina
has a long history as a House member of
in the financial services industry
pushing back against the banks and the
the financial services that don't like
Bitcoin because it disrupts their
business uh Blake Masters who is
embraced it totally uh coming out of
Silicon Valley in his work background
running in Arizona the fellow I
mentioned bohinz in North Carolina who's
studied a cryptocurrency law in law
school he he understands he knows what
gas fees are I mean you ask any other
member of Congress what's in them they'd
scratch that they say well it's over
five dollars when I was on my car
exactly so we got a lot of work to do
um and when we decided to embrace this
at the club we're all in but we've put
together a strategy that has you know
five different components one of its
political electing those Champions but a
lot of its education bringing the
leaders in Washington influence people
up to speed on what Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency is some of its advocacy
presenting the arguments why it's good
for society and why it should be left
alone essentially and so it can Thrive
and develop and innovate and some of it
would be working with outside groups to
litigate you know if if the SEC
continues to play favorites in that area
and leave murky with a threat of over
regulation well sometimes you got to go
to court and force them to do the right
thing that's kind of the last not not
most extreme but you keep that in your
back pocket if Last Resort
we also recognized the more we can keep
this bipartisan the better off we are
now Club for Growth as you pointed out
is partisan we tend to support
Republicans but I've I have some good
friends on the Democrat side who are
also big fans of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency and we've agreed to work
with each other you know we'll agree to
disagree on an election but but when it
comes back together to Advocate to get
both sides of the aisle to work towards
that is that common on some issues where
there's some issues where people say hey
this is just too important for the
partisanship or it used to be you were
asking what it was like it used to be
National Security was was bipartisan the
the politics stopped at the boundary and
and America in the world we were we were
bipartisan and keeping keeping us strong
um but today it's very hard I mean the
let's just put it this way and it would
shock everybody your listeners if some
of them are up in Washington listening
David actually has friends who are
Democrats that that's unusual but it's
true and and my view is do the right
thing and work with people on both sides
who want to do the right thing yeah and
something like Bitcoin it's a
fascinating
um Topic in general it's a financial
asset that people can go buy and it goes
up and down in US dollar value uh there
is a infrastructure component to it with
Bitcoin mining and we've seen the oil
and gas industry really Embrace that and
and see hey there may be a way for us to
monetize our energy production in a more
profitable way uh there is a what I'll
consider an individual liberty or
individual rights of sovereignty
whatever aspect to uh being able to
actually hold your own assets and and uh
kind of uh leave with some portion of
your wealth a fractional Reserve System
and all that and then there ends up
being this like privacy and surveillance
uh um aspect not so much as to using a
public Ledger uh provides you privacy
but it is a uh uh very polar opposite to
the promise of Central Bank digital
currencies and some of the surveillance
work and and things that are would be
possible there
when you look at that is there one of
those areas where it seems like
politicians have gravitated more towards
is it the financial asset is it oh
there's job creation and in terms of
infrastructure is it you know I really
care about privacy and so the the
opposite of cbdc's is kind of what I
want to back or how do you see them kind
of interacting with this that's a great
question I think it would depend on
their orientation so the more
libertarian political leaders are are
completely with us at the club on saying
the cbdc is a terrible idea
um in part because of you don't need it
and it expands government power but in
part because of that privacy and the
ability of the government to come in and
tax your transactions through the
currency or come in and spy on you
essentially and see everything that
you've you've spent your money on
um by the way we pulled that
in a national poll of battleground
states in the country and well over 50
percent I think is 53 reject the idea
that the government should have a its
own coin interesting when you point out
these risks that opposition increases to
almost 60 percent so the American public
intuitively knows this is a bad idea
um but that'd be the focus of
Libertarians the focus of of people in
the energy carbon energy industry and
then on the other side the
environmentalist is on the mining and
the these environmental groups that have
been you know paid money out of the the
guys from Ripple are at the state level
like in New York they passed a somewhat
of a ban on it they've been advocating
at the White House Science office on why
it's bad for climate change a ridiculous
paper I'll shared with you our response
that we're going to be releasing today
or tomorrow pointing out how bad the
science is behind that but the political
motive there is to attack the Bitcoin
mining
and then the energy sector realizes as
you pointed out this is a way we can
optimize the what we're producing the
what used to be flared off as as waste
material can now be used to generate the
power to do this mining by the way there
are some good environmental groups that
look at at Bitcoin mining and say no
this is actually a good development
because it's increasing the use of
alternative energy so you know people
who aren't steeped in the politics of US
versus them on the environmental side
realize this is actually a good
development one of our missions is to
bring that forward and and tell people
about it yeah there's a ESG analyst I
think his name is Daniel Batten and I I
had a conversation with him
um I believe he's if I remember
correctly is based in Australia and uh
he said listen I I care about the
environment right and I'm an investor
and he says when I came across Bitcoin
mining and gassler capture and all this
stuff uh he's gone so far as to now uh
at least the the content I see majority
of it is Bitcoin related and I think
he's even raising his next fund
specifically around the infrastructure
of Bitcoin and it's fascinating because
you know he's not the person that they
would normally expect to be the
proponent I'd love to reach out to him
and tell him what we're trying to do to
educate people because another thing
that you guys care a lot about I think
is rolling back a lot of the
environmental regulations
um but to talk a little bit there and I
think this intersection you mentioned a
couple of times woke capital or woke
capitalism
um it feels like Europe specifically uh
is feeling the negative side effects of
pursuing some of these
um maybe theoretical exercises right
kind of the the Greta thundberg let's
just go all renewable let's get rid of
all of our power plants and and
avoid nuclear power plants like all the
stuff and like now there's an energy
crisis and they're paying you know 2x
for energy from China that's really just
marked up and renamed Russian energy
um so kind of talk through that a little
bit Yeah and and I have a lot of history
in the environmental area back when I
was
working for H.W bush and Dan Quayle we
reviewed all the different environmental
regulations it in some ways it's almost
like a religion
um and and therefore
um if you say this is good for the
environment then it becomes we're going
to adopt that even if it's bad for
people I mean the simple truth is energy
is necessary for everything we do in
life for getting around for moving for
heating our houses for cooling our
houses for Life as we know it
um and so you you've got to have a
source for that energy we all want to
reduce the pollution elements of it but
the environmental movement has grabbed
that as they did in Europe as a source
of a way of controlling what choices
people make rather than optimizing
what's actually good for them so my
belief is we've got to push back on
these regulatory structures
and we used when I was doing the review
in government a cost-benefit analysis
what are the benefits from the
regulation in cleaner environment
healthier safer and what are the costs
of people losing their jobs less economy
and oftentimes the costs way outweighed
the benefits and then I think we should
ask ourselves can we accomplish the goal
in a easier way I'm a big believer in
incentives so if you want to have less
pollution pay people to pollute less
right rather than come in it's kind of
the old Soviet model we'll be command
and control tell you exactly how to run
that plant or run that Factory and then
slow down your productivity versus if we
just tell somebody hey if you pollute
less you're going to make more money
they'll figure out a way they'll do it
faster and better using the incentive
structure so there's lots of problems in
that area and the cost of those
government regulations are almost equal
to or more than the cost per employee of
taxes and so we we are worried that jobs
are being sent to China and Mexico and
other countries if we can lower the cost
per employee of doing business in the
U.S then we'll have more jobs and more
opportunity yeah you're a fascinating
guy because you obviously have the club
for growth and the work you guys are
doing there and it requires you to
understand the economy and requires you
understand politics a lot of technology
these different things but you almost
had like a life before this which was in
politics itself
um but my understanding is that when you
were in college you created the
Federalist Society for Law and public
policy uh which I I heard you describe
it as uh just a couple of people sitting
around having pizza at first
and now there was some influence that
you all had and some participation in
literally picking Supreme Court Justices
and and helping to kind of do the
vetting process maybe walk me through
like what is that organization and how
did it go from some pizzas to Supreme
Court participation if you will and so
it did we we looked around and said hey
um conservative principles in this case
that the constitution is what's made
America great and there's a role for
judges to interpret the law but they're
not elected so they shouldn't make new
law
um and that basic principle we we you
know there were seven or eight of us
that got together talked about it had
pizza and we thought well let's form a
group and and we'll meet regularly and
then we held a conference at Yale and
invited people like Robert Bork and Nino
Scalia to come
um Scalia was one of my professors so he
helped Inspire this
um and they did they didn't know each
other and said this is fun but we also
grounded in the principle of debate so
we invited liberals to come and debate
with us and and Libertarians and
traditional conservatives and different
viewpoints after law school we were
having so much fun we said well let's
keep going
um and formed a group in Washington
hired a couple people to set up chapters
and and run it and so over the 40 years
it's grown it gained in reputation
because it was grounded in debate we
didn't take positions but we so we
allowed all different views to come and
discuss and debate that so the liberal
professors that were kind of bored at
law school where it was all uniform
everybody believed the same thing they
liked coming and debating and having
their ideas challenged and and the
conservatives had a voice and a platform
well eventually when when Trump was
President he turned to the federal
society and said give me a list of
people that you think could be good on
the Supreme Court
um and one of the leaders gave that list
to him he said okay this is my list I'm
going to do it
and what I noticed when he was president
um he we would talk periodically he'd
call me up and we'd mostly talk politics
like what do you think about this race
but sometimes he just asked questions
what about this
he kept asking what about my next
Supreme Court appointee I guess he knew
I was one of the founders of the
Federalist Society
um and I kept saying Amy Coney Barrett
um oh yeah everybody likes Amy but what
about other people let me talk about it
so the opening came up and
um Justice Ginsburg passed and he called
and said so David what do you think and
I knew he was getting advice to be
political about it a point
of somebody who's a good judge but
because she was Latina
and versus just straight merits and I I
said to him Mr President I'm still for
Amy Coney Barrett and he said yeah I
know I know but I could tell I hadn't
persuaded him
um so I said well
remember the last appointment you did
you were you were kind of disappointed
with some of the rulings and I I knew he
wasn't happy about a couple things who
was the person
um it was uh gosh a name just went out
of my mind his second appointment and
the and I said you know what we we
didn't know much about him
um so sometimes you'll get rulings you
like sometimes you won't
with Amy you know exactly what you're
gonna get because she's been vetted
people have watched her she's been in
experienced before if you pick somebody
else that's kind of new you're not sure
what you're going to get by the way
that's the whole thesis the Federalist
Society has look at get experienced
people see how they've performed in
lower position and then put them on the
Supreme Court
so a couple days later he announced it
was Amy Coney Barrett and I was glad to
see that I don't know whether it was me
or other people that talked him into it
but the I think that's one of his best
appointments because she is grounded in
that constitution in The Limited role of
Judges
um
if you'd have told me back when I was in
law school someday David you'd be
advising a president about who should be
on the Supreme Court I would have
laughed
me you got to be kidding yeah um but
it's been a great experience and the
success is because it's built around
ideas and the principle of debate yeah
and in those situations like what is the
process like right so when you talk
about like vetting and and kind of
watching is it just hey here's the the
details of a case and this is how they
ruled and you just see that over and
over and over again you kind of know
what you're going to get or like what
was like the vetting process look like
is it an interview you know where they
come sit down for two hours and and you
uh ask a bunch of crazy questions or
like what is it like yeah so um one of
my first jobs in government was with
attorney general Meese and and he really
set up that vetting process for
Republicans before that it was kind of
politics who did the president know you
know who did the Senators recommend and
we would interview the those judges one
if they had been on the lower court or
look at everything everything they'd
ever written so and the the idea was
things that they put down in writing and
done before that reveals their core
beliefs and approach but then we'd
interview them and instead of asking
about politics like what's your view on
abortion or what do you think about gay
rights or what do you think about civil
rights and civil liberties we would give
them actually
hypotheticals that would be real cases
and say not just what's your bottom line
result how do you get to that result and
we'd look and say okay if they if their
reasoning was grounded in the
Constitution and the right correct role
for govern for judges then that's the
type of Judge we want to recommend the
president a point so it was a very
thorough vetting process and Republican
administrations have done that since
then
um my senses Democrats have also done
more of that you look at Obama's
appointees and maybe because he was a
law professor himself he he cared a lot
about the way they thought about rulings
and making decisions and I think that's
good for the country they're not playing
politics putting their best friend on
the court they're trying to find people
who will do a good job as as a judge
yeah the presidents do they call
regularly like it sounds like you Trump
you probably spoke to a little bit more
uh Biden or Obama do they call they
don't call me
um no although um Club for Growth was
called by the Obama folks because we
were for free trade and they wanted to
get some bipartisan help on some of that
interesting so we worked with them that
way so the and I know very little about
politics which uh will be quick to
understand here but the presidents
obviously have some partisanship is how
they usually get uh elected
um but it is very rare for them to reach
across the aisle for the non-profits or
other types of organizations and kind of
get the other side that's right most of
the time they'll look for their allies
and and ask them what they think is it
because they
believe hey if I called David uh he's
gonna tell me no and and like slam the
phone and you know and and not be
interested or is it again going back to
kind of the governors of just like
playing to the base or playing to the
people they know and have work you know
it would be a smart thing for them to
test what the other side thinks about
things yeah and have some friends there
that would be honest with them I think
they assume they're the opposition so if
I call them and if say President Biden
called me which I don't think is going
to happen his folks wouldn't have it
I'll have my people talk to his people
right talk to other people
um they would worry that I would then go
to a reporter and tell them about the
conversation right interesting so and to
use it for my own benefit rather than to
help them as an advisor
um so hopefully president either
personally or through a trusted advisor
have some connections on the other side
that they listened to used to happen in
Congress the the Senators on both sides
of the aisle would talk with each other
privately and respect those
conversations doesn't happen it's so
divided now it's like uh TMZ who can
leak uh the information as fast as
possible into the media right is that
because the media has gotten better at
like infiltrating uh and building trust
and so they just get more information or
is it because the politicians and those
in that apparatus have learned how to
weaponize the media against their
opponents a huge coin of the realm in
Washington is information you give to a
reporter so people will leak things
they'll talk to them all the time the
reporters cultivate group of people that
they call and and get information get
leads on stories
um
so
more now that he's out of office but the
folks around president Trump have a
group of reporters that they talk to and
so I've experienced when when he would
call me about a race I'd notice a few
days later that part of that
conversation would be written up
somewhere in the Press really yeah so
that means I'm gonna meet her what I'm
saying recognizing some of it'll be
public
now if I really wanted to communicate
something to him I'd call his cell when
he was out in the golf course and tell
him and he might share that with other
people or he might not but that that was
his choice whereas if there was a big
group listening in on the call A lot of
times they'd leak for their own benefit
not necessarily for the principal's
benefit yeah it's frustrating in in when
you're an executive and you want to have
confidential conversations you really
have to get people that you trust
completely yeah this is a ridiculous
question but I have to ask you uh well
first have you ever gone golfing with
Trump no I'm a terrible golfer okay so
am I but I've been on the golf course
and someone has called me before yeah
and so you know I'm a younger person who
has airpods and so I put my airpods that
except flying but I always wondered uh
if Trump got a phone call on the golf
course does he stop playing or does he
like do the you know hold it with the
shoulder and try to swing or something
I've never been there to watch yeah most
of the time it goes to voicemail let's
just put it that way
because I'm golfing yeah I've always
wondered that because I I I've seen the
photos and he's like you know sitting on
the on the green and he's got the phone
or whatever yeah and you're like okay I
guess he just stops stops uh um when you
think of young people in their
participation last thing I want to talk
about is uh the fellowship that you all
run
um you have this really interesting
program where uh you are taking young
people and there's an education
component to it what does that program
look like who are the types of people
who go through it and I guess like how
do you measure whether it's successful
or not on the other side yeah so
um one I kind of realized as we were
vetting candidates for
um Congress that the Club for Growth
pack would the support and endorse there
weren't enough there weren't enough
people to meet and to to kind of think
about supporting so I thought let's
not set up something for candidates but
let's create a network of leaders who
are maybe in their late 20s 30s and
early 40s that
established doing things in life but
younger ready maybe hopefully someday
want to do public service
and let's train them in the principles
of free market economics Liberty
principles
teach them how government works so that
if they're engaging with it they realize
you know these politicians have
incentives that guide them to maximize
their political contributions whether
it's good or not
teach teach them a lot of that but also
give them some media training so they
can be articulate spokesman in their
Community for the principles that we
care about and so we started three years
ago this fellowship program invited 50
people to apply each year and like the
Federalist Society we decided let's
create a network where they know each
other they get to meet each other
getting together it happened right
during covid so it took us a long time
to have that in-person meeting
and they could compare notes somebody
who's on City Council in Connecticut
could talk to somebody in Colorado who's
working on the same issue and share what
worked what what their experience was
um that it's amazing to me it it's been
already very successful one of our first
years fellow is now the head of the
Heritage Foundation
he's a very smart younger guy as they
move to Next Generation leadership three
of them ran for congress this year and
won their primaries so they will be
Congressman next year one of them a lady
in South Carolina was passionate about
that school choice we talked about and
she ran for superintendent of education
and won that race wow so we're starting
to see them move into these leadership
positions and next weekend we're going
to be together in Washington bringing
them all back and having them continue
to build that Fellowship that
colleague if any of your listeners are
interested it's Club for Growth
our foundation sponsors it and we open
up applications in November I'd love to
what you wish for yeah I hope we get a
lot of them because I I'm a big believer
in the Next Generation in this country
Pop
um you know I I'm a spiritual guy I pray
about what I do I ask for God's guidance
and blessing and about a year into the
job I had this strong sense that yeah
David you're going to go back and do
politics now and you know you'll help
get people elected we're going to be
passionate about freedom but what I
really want you to do is identify help
elect maybe but Mentor this next
generation of leaders for our country
and so for me it's it's not only my job
it's kind of a spiritual calling that I
can give back to them now I have to be
honest with you to get there there and I
think God did this to me he had to wring
out the desire for me to be the guy you
know the candidate who goes and gets
elected the guy who might be president
Someday I'm done with that in my life
but I want to give back to this next
generation and turn over the country to
them because I was blessed growing up in
America a guy who grew up in a little
town had Big Dreams got to follow them
and pursue them and I want to see that
be the country that we have for kids
that are growing up now yeah to go from
a guy from a little town in Indiana to
talking to the president on a cell phone
pretty big deal it is and I counted as a
great blessing yeah where uh where can
we send people to find you on the
internet uh or more about Club for
Growth yeah so
clubforg.org is the handle there uh Club
for Growth Foundation has that
Fellowship but look at it look us up
clubforgrowth.org you can see that my
number in Washington's
202-955-5500 if someone's coming to DC
wants to connect with us I'd love to
talk to
I don't think we've ever had someone
give out their uh uh number on the shop
right now because I don't know what's
going to happen I don't know if you get
a lot of calls are done
I'll let you know awesome well listen
thank you so much for uh for taking the
time to do this I I learned a ton I
think a lot of folks in the audience
will have as well
in the future one thing we're so
passionate about Bitcoin and and the
future there we set up a whole new
political group called Bitcoin Freedom
pack
um so we're actually going to engage in
the political process to elect those
Champions there's a lot of people I
think uh who would be uh behind that who
are listening to this thank you